mathematical research can feel very
self-indulgent and and and teaching for
me is kind of an answer to that where I
really get to share with people with
other people what I what I love doing I
think one one challenge is that
mathematics has a difficult petition and
I think that many people are ready to
shut off as soon as they as soon as they
hear the word mathematics I get a lot of
negative reactions when I say that I'm a
mathematician and I really believe that
that that everybody can have joyful math
experiences I really believe this and
and it's a challenge to implement it and
and I really believe that in a classroom
you can not just tailor the class to the
students that are getting the highest
grades that everybody can really benefit
but so that's my challenge is to is to
make is to make sure that that happens
and it can be difficult when you know
you have students that you know they
have three jobs sometimes they arrive to
class hungry
they're paying for their for their
parents rent and they have you know the
little time that they have available to
do mathematics and so those realities
are are complex and and I think it's
important to remember that that doesn't
mean that this student is not talented
that or not interested you know and so a
challenge and a joy is to is to get the
best work and our students and to see
their full potential and I think one
thing that I try doing a lot is
structuring my classroom in a way that I
really values everybody's voice and I
think the biggest joy is when you have
somebody who's been sitting in the back
and very quiet and kind of not really a
very comfortable kind of speaking in
their mathematical voice and then having
them find their mathematical boys and
having having them find their joy and
having them kind of be able to express
themselves and that's that's really one
of my favorite things is and as an
educator